I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello! Are you being a whistleblower, Angela?
I was trying, I have the most pitiful whistle. Hello and welcome to the finale of season six, Whistle Blower, also episode 26. This was such a big season. It was crazy. I want to start off today apologizing if I sound a little nasally. I'm working out some head congestion. Just got a little bit of a stuffy nose. I know, can you hear it?
I feel like you can hear it. Lee said you can hear it. He said I should acknowledge it when I got on air. I can hear it. Okay. It doesn't bother me, lady. Well, he said, just right off the bat, if you just acknowledge it, then you know it's fine.
It's like when I had food poisoning. I was like, hey, we're talking to Ellie. I also sound like I just crawled out of the bathroom. Exactly. Yeah. Okay. So there we go. It's been said.
Now moving on. To Whistle Blower. Yeah. Whistle Blower, which was written by Warren Lieberstein and Hal Stead Sullivan and directed by Paul Lieberstein. I have a very short summary. It is one sentence long, but I think it really sums it up. Okay.
An angry Joe Bennett descends upon Dunder Mifflin Scranton to identify which employee talked to the press about Saber's faulty printers prompting the group to turn on Andy. Lady, I have to say, I hadn't watched this episode since it aired. Same. Yeah. And I really enjoyed it. I did too. There's so many great moments.
Well, there's a lot of Kathy Bates in this episode and that made me very happy. There's a lot of Joe and Michael, which I could not get enough of. Same. I mean, they're two amazing actors doing amazing work. Yeah. All right. Fastback number one, like we said, this is the season six finale. It aired on May 20th, 2010 and was watched by 6.6 million households.
Now if I remember correctly, Angela, we were originally only going to do 24 episodes and at the last minute, suddenly we were doing 26. This was confirmed by our writers, Warren and Halstead. Yes, because we reached out to them for this episode and they shared with us lots of fun behind the scenes stuff that we'll share and sprinkle through the episode. Well, Warren and Halstead did share with us that the finale had this dual purpose of both having to wrap up season six as well as set things up for season seven. You know, in past years, our season finales have had some pretty big cliff hangers and
this one has a few, but they're maybe not as dramatic as other years. Right. But you know what's interesting about that to me? If you have been watching all along, which we have now, right, we're watching every week, just when Michael mentions Holly, that felt so huge to me. Yes. Okay. I remember that at this time, we knew that Steve would only be coming back for season
seven and that was it. Yeah. By the time we did this episode, it was, we found out kind of a few episodes before the end of season six. So the writers knew that that season seven would be his last and Warren and Halstead shared that they had started brainstorming what Steve's last year might look like. And the big thing that they settled on was that they wanted him to ultimately find happiness with Holly and that was going to be a seed that was planted in this season finale.
But besides that, they only set up two other things. They set up that Dwight was going to buy the building and we start to see Erin kind of warming up to Andy. She touches his calf kind of and lets her hand linger there for a minute. Like a lingering calf touch for sure. Lingering calf touch. Well, like you said, Warren and Halstead were awesome and we've got some fun little tidbits from them for this episode.
Thank you guys. Yeah. Are you ready for fast fact number two? I'm so ready. Please tell me it's a location breakdown of a private plane. It sure is, lady. We shot that private plane on location at the Van Nuys Airport on board an actual private plane that was not a set.
We got some fan mail. People wondered if we built the interior of a fakie plane. No, that was a real plane and it was very narrow. And our camera operators, that was a bit of a challenge to figure out how to shoot because they couldn't move any seats. They couldn't move any walls. They were just crammed in there. Our production designer, Michael Gallenberg, was friends with a senior executive at the
aviation company called Castle & Cook. And because of that, we were able to use their hangar and the interior of their jet for a cost of only $10,000. Plus we had to pay the Van Nuys Airport Authority a $5,000 usage fee. Oh, the usage fees. You know those. Dang usage fees. So Castle & Cook is a real aviation company and it only exists in Van Nuys, California
and Honolulu, Hawaii. So you are not going to ever find this anywhere near Scranton, Pennsylvania. But Warren and Halstead shared that they were writing this script up to the very last minute and by the time they got the idea to shoot on a private plane, they did not have time to change the Castle & Cook signage to something else. They couldn't make like a giant new hangar sign. Yeah. So they just went with it.
Incidentally, Castle & Cook is part of the company that originally owned Dole Fruit. What? Yeah. They are one of the largest suppliers of Hawaiian pineapples. Well, I guess they fly them on their planes. I guess. Oh, who knows? Who knows?
I would hope that if I'm on a Castle & Cook private plane, someone serves me some fresh Hawaiian pineapple. And if they don't, you'll bring it up. I sure will. I'll be like, you guys, you don't even have any canned pineapple back there. It's your thing. Well, listen, they didn't have time to change the big sign, but there are some really great details on the plane.
Thanks to our set decorator, Steve Rothstein. I noticed one. What did you notice? Are those Joe's initials? There's like a little fancy looking, I don't know what you call it. It goes over the chair, like for your head. Yes. Cloth, yes.
What are those called? I don't know what they're called. They're like, they're on the headrest. Like a doily for an airplane. Yes. They were little cloths on the headrest, and they were embroidered with JB for Joe Bennett. That was my question. I was going to say, is that real embroidery because it looked fancy?
Oh yeah. He had those made. Also, and I'll point out with a time code when we get there, on the outside of the plane, they do have a big sticker that is Joe Bennett's signature as a logo. Oh, so cool. Like she signed the outside of her plane. I love little details like that. All right.
Are you ready for FastFact number three, Angela? I know you are because you were a big part of making this happen. Yes. I'm very excited about FastFact three. FastFact three is all about our guest star, Nelson Franklin as Nick the IT guy. You guys know that Nelson has appeared in five episodes of The Office, and this is his last one. And I believe, Ange, that he has the distinction of being the only actor to play two different
roles on the show. I think that is correct. Now you guys out there who are just the diehard office fans might have some stats for us that we're not thinking of right now, but I feel like Nelson is the one that immediately comes to mind to me because he was in job fair. Yes. And two years later, he has this arc as Nick the IT guy, and Angela, you know him. You worked with him recently on Black AF and you reached out to him.
Yes. We were co-stars on Black AF and we got to spend all day together because our characters were writers and we were in a writer's room and we got to like improvise and we just had the best time together. Nelson is one of the nicest people you will ever meet. I was so excited to reconnect with him. And this is what he said about how he got his job on the office. Hi, Angela.
Hi, Jenna. It's me, Nelson. Thank you so much for having me on the show. I'm such a big fan of your podcast and obviously I love the office and I love you too very much. And so this is a big thrill for me. Thank you so much for having me. Let's get into these questions.
Number one, how did I get my job on the office? And had I seen the show before being cast, oh hell yeah, I'd seen the show before being cast. It was my favorite show. Literally my favorite show. It was one of the biggest shows in the country, if not the world at the time. So it was a very big deal for me to get this job. And how I got the job, it was just a good old fashioned audition.
Went in and ran for Alison Jones, of course, who we all like to reminisce about fondly and with love because she's the greatest and she deserves all the praise she can get. But I would also like to add that when I auditioned for the office, it was for the job fair in season four. And that was my first paid acting job out of college, if you can believe it. It was like 21 at the time and it was insane, it was a big deal for me to get on the show. So yes, I auditioned. I did not realize that we were his first gig.
I had no idea. You would never know. No. I mean, I did that scene with him at job fair. I never suspected that that was his first television gig. I feel like I was way more nervous and like, obviously, deer in headlights at my first acting gig. I know.
I mean, Nelson, you were so composed. Yeah, such a pro. Well, listen, Anjuan, you said you were going to reach out to him. I had to know how is it that he ended up playing these two different roles on the show and you asked him, right? I did. I did. And here's what he said.
Yes, it's true. I did play two different characters on the office and I believe I was the only one or this is being confirmed by you guys and that's amazing. I always wondered if I was the only one. So, you know, as I said, the job fair, that was my first job ever. It was supposed to be like a little one-off thing. I was totally unknown, literally unknown. It was my first job.
It made me taft hardly or whatever you call it and you got to join the union. And basically, Allison brought me back in two years later for the IT guy role because I was right for it and I'm basically an IT guy already. And I read and Greg and Mike Schur and those guys were like, oh, no, you can't be two people on the same show in the same universe. It doesn't work. It's too bad. We know that was his first gig and we would have wanted to give him something bigger,
but he already used up his one role. So that's not going to happen. And that was sad. And then they read more people for like a week and then after a little while they came back to me and we're like, yeah, you know what, fine, you get the job. And what a thrill that was being told no. And then being like, actually, remember when we said you didn't have that job? Well, you do.
And I said to Greg, like, what made you change your mind? And he said, no one's going to remember that you were the jobs fair guy. No one's going to remember that. It was 25 seconds at the end of an episode. Just don't bring it up to anybody who asks. No one's ever going to know. And I said, Greg, it's pretty feasible that a guy who was a graphics design person would then, you know, pivot into an IT guy career.
That's totally believable. And he was like, no, no, no, no, just don't mention it. No one's ever going to know. And boy, was he wrong because, you know, the office fans are voracious. They know every detail of every second of every episode. So yeah, it became a folklore hero basically is the end of this question. I love that so much. He was trying to justify it.
Yeah. He was like, you know what, let's just we'll have a little thing where maybe I got it. Like Pam's like, hey, and he's like, yeah, I'm in IT now. That's all it would have taken. All I would have taken is one line and then he's the same character. Yeah. Same guy. Now we know his name is Nick.
I don't think, do we know his name before? I don't even know. Job fair? I don't know. I think he's just graphic design guy. That cracked me up. And of course, we always ask our guests if they're still recognized from being on the office and here's what Nelson had to say.
Yeah, absolutely. That's like the number one thing I get recognized for. I mean, you know, the office, as I said, it was just such a big deal. It's got the most fans of any show I've ever known. I mean, it's totally ubiquitous. People from all walks of life watch the office and so I get recognized constantly. The other thing that happens is people come up to me and be like, wait a second, I know you.
Are you Tom's brother? No, no, no, you were at that concert last night and then I just after I let them flail around for a second and they say, IT guy and they go, oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, got it, got it. All right. Then they flip me off because they remember that scene. He gets flipped off. That's hilarious.
Well, he's got a big moment at the end of the episode. I know. It's pretty great. I know. You get people saying, don't throw a garbage at me. I get saved bandit, but he gets the finger. Well, Andrew also asked if he took anything from the show when he left and I loved his response because it made me remember a thing that I had forgotten.
Okay. You know, I wish I had that seems like a great idea to swipe something a little memento, but I didn't do it. I did take a cell phone picture of the like sort of whiteboard. There's like a dry erase board that somebody was keeping up the second 80 or something where it would have the names of the guest stars that were appearing in the episode for whatever reason. And the handwriting was super bad, so I have this great picture of this dry erase board
where it says like Kathy Bates and then right under it says Nelson. And it's like written like a sort of like a drunk person wrote it on there. It's just a fond memory. That's the only thing I kept. I remember that whiteboard and you know what's crazy in our final season. I was going around, I was just taking pictures of things because I just wanted to remember every detail. Yeah.
I took a picture of the whiteboard. You did. And it would have our like our numbers on it. Each cast member was assigned a number and it would say like who's in the scene? Who's on deck? Yeah. And it would have guest stars and it would have all these numbers. It was like a code like we knew what it all meant, but somebody coming in to visit may
not know. Yeah. It's like how, you know, I think so many baseball stats. I'm like, what's that? Yeah. Like that. And it was by the back door as you walked into our set right there on the wall. So the minute you walked in, you knew who was in the scene?
Who was up next? Who was in the background of the scene? Right. Exactly. He was speaking. Yeah. And I mean, my gosh, if I saw my name on a whiteboard next, I'd have a picture of that. Yeah.
Well, he is just wonderful. I loved hearing from him and we have more clips. Yes. He's going to share a few more things about his time on the office and we'll be adding those in as we talk about this episode. Well, why don't we take a break and then we'll get into this episode. Okay. We would not make good whistleblowers, clearly, not if it involves actually whistling.
This episode starts with Michael watching a clip of himself defending Saber on the local news. Yes. And then Todd Packer calls because everybody's seeing him on the news and of course he knows this. Oh, tickled. Oh, he loves it. He's probably rewatched this clip over and over.
I want to say at 14 seconds, Packer has a line where he says, I want to pinch your tiny wiener. Yeah. Yeah. Uh-huh. The original table draft for this episode had the line, I want to lick your tiny wiener. Oh, my goodness. But standards and practices said no.
Okay. So they had to change lick to pinch and then it got approved. I have become fascinated by standards and practices. Who is that person that scrubs through our episodes with the red flag? Yeah. And it's like, we're going to no licking of the tiny penis, please. We need to change that. We need to change that.
I also would just love, love to have been a fly on the wall for their meetings about our show. I know. Are the email exchanges? I mean, that is some digital clutter I'd like to get my hands on. Same. While Michael is watching his news clip, did you happen to see the other news of the day? Oh, yes.
Yeah. It's all listed on the right hand side of the computer screen. Here are the news stories of the day and Scranton. Okay. Number one, local teacher wrongly accused of pedophilia. We're going to discuss that later. Yes. Mm-hmm.
Number two, area business manager responds to allegations. That's Michael. Mm-hmm. It's written in blue because it's the one Michael's watching. Nice detail. Mm-hmm. Number three, local zoo gets a baby otter. Oh, yeah.
Number four, last of three murder suspects arrested. Hmm. Number five, former fire secretary sentenced for theft. Wow. Number six, expert, semicolon, bill likely to be ruled constitutional. Okay. Okay. Very vague.
I know. Number seven, ex-state rep convicted in bonus gate scandal. Bonus gate. I'm intrigued. Number eight, parents pack meeting to hear about drugs in schools. And lastly, if you notice, Michael's clip has 1,069 views. Okay. Well, he's going to have a talking head where he brags about all of his views and all the
people who are watching his clip. He even called the radio request line and talked about it on the air. Yeah. Well, we had a fan catch from Kelly W., from Cary, North Carolina, and many others who said, Michael says he called Froggy 98.7. But all of the stickers and the magnets throughout the office say Froggy 101. Was this a continuity error or just Michael not knowing what he's doing? He asked Warren and Hallstead about this and they said, this was a goof.
Yeah. They know that fans have spotted this. It is totally their bad. And they can't believe that they wrote Froggy 98.7 and that none of us noticed. We've been surrounded by these bumper stickers for like seven years. Seven years. There's one on the file cabinet by Phyllis's desk. Here's the thing though.
I think they wrote 98.7. This is my theory because there's a local Los Angeles radio station that plays pop music, like whatever the billboard charts are, and it's 98.7. And I think that just went sort of from their brain right to the page. It must have. But it's very funny to me that everyone caught it. But we didn't. Well, now Michael's going to run out of his office and he is going to declare DEF CON
5. Do you know why? Dun, dun, dun. He is the number two most watched clip on the local news and we cannot have that. He has to watch his clip now. Yeah. He said he wants everyone to stop what they're doing and watch his clip 11 times. But pretty quickly, Angela gets distracted by that cute otter.
And then everybody gets distracted by the cute otter. It's everybody watching the otter and it's making Michael crazy. But then I loved it because Michael goes to watch it and he's like, I don't need it. And then he's clearly charmed by the otter. Well, I got a little interested in him calling DEF CON 5 because, you know, DEF CON 5, it actually stands for the lowest state of readiness. It means everything's going great and nothing's wrong. DEF CON 1 is we are in the middle of a nuclear war.
I just remember it from that Matthew Broderick movie. Yes. War games. War games. All the DEF CONs. Yes. Well, I did a mini deep dive on the DEF CONs and I personally found it fascinating, so I'm going to share.
Let's hear it. Well, DEF CON stands for Defense Readiness Condition. It is controlled by the President and the U.S. Secretary of Defense through the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff and the combatant commanders. And different branches of the armed forces can have different DEF CONs going on at once. So many DEF CONs. One person can be DEF CON 5 and someone else might be a DEF CON 3. Here are the different DEF CONs.
5 means lowest state of readiness for everybody. Yes. Depending on wherever your DEF CONs are. That's right. Got it. DEF CON 4 means Increased Intelligence Watch and Strengthened Security. If you go to DEF CON 3, it means that we need an increase in force readiness above that that is required for normal readiness and the Air Force needs to be ready to mobilize in
15 minutes. That means they're calling everybody. Hey, folks, you got to come in. Yep. Yep. You got to be ready to fly in 15 minutes. DEF CON 2 is the next step to nuclear war. Oh, my Lord.
And armed forces need to be ready to deploy and engage in less than six hours. DEF CON 1 means nuclear war is imminent or has already begun. We're all dead. DEF CON 1, we're all dead. Yes. Nuclear war is in progress. Goodbye, planet. Well, as of 2014, the worldwide DEF CON level has never been more severe than DEF CON 3.
When was that? Since 2014. Okay. But the U.S. did reach DEF CON 2 twice. Yeah. Remember, DEF CON 2 means Next Step Nuclear War. Was that with Cuba? Yes.
The 1962 Cuban Missile Crisis and the 1991 Gulf War. We went to DEF CON 2 for a short period of time. Yikes. Mm-hmm. I'm happy to be at DEF CON 5 with Michael. Yes. Even though he seems panicked by it. Yeah.
DEF CON 5, everyone. Well, I find that so interesting, Jenna. And I also, like, as you were describing all of it, I imagine you and I in front of a huge boardroom, all the different heads of the military, all their accolades, and you and I, like, kind of dressed like the moms we are in front of a dry erase board breaking down DEF CON. Like, could you imagine if we were called in and you're like, here's DEF CON 4, and I'm like, yeah, everybody show up, time to get dressed, got a report to work.
Well, that's DEF CON 3. Got it wrong. I draw an arrow to it from 4 to 3. From 4 to 3. From 4 to 3. Yeah. Mm-hmm. Nothing has gone very wrong if we are the people explaining the DEF CONs.
I have to say. It would make a great scene in Mom Detectives, though. It sure would. You could have, like, a DEF CON, like, home edition. Mm-hmm. You know? Yeah. Where it's more...
Oh. I don't know what it is. Susie Chihuahua is out and there was reports of a coyote in the neighborhood. DEF CON 2. DEF CON 2. Yeah. Yeah. There's a permanent attack pending.
Yes. DEF CON 2. DEF CON 2. All right. We did get fan questions for the scene. Should I pivot to those? Yes. Let's go back to the episode.
All right. Marnie W. from Dallas, Texas says, everyone was watching Michael's press release on a YouTube-esque website, but it doesn't look like YouTube. Was this a fakie site? Yes, it was, Marnie. It was meant to be the website for the local news. So it was, you know, like a video playback. Randy said it was created by a company called Playback Technologies.
They created the fakie website and they also had to send a playback operator and a playback technician to make all the videos pop up on our various screens. And then we had a fan catch from Frankie C. in Seattle, Washington, who says, Hi, office ladies. My name is Frankie and I'm 14 years old. I have watched the office five times and I have a question about the cold open of whistleblower. Okay. Frankie, what you got?
Michael asked the whole office to watch his video and everyone's sound is playing at the same time. But you guys have mentioned in previous podcasts that Oscar was the only one to really have sound on his computer. So true, Frankie. So how did this work? Well, Randy said all of the computers ran the videos without sound and they actually added that in later in post-production.
So we're fakie reacting to sound. Yep. Exactly. The video, fakie sound. And finally, Randy said that the video of the baby otters was footage from the Monterey California Aquarium. But you know, the otters do not end up doing any of the things that Michael describes in his final talking head.
That's why you don't see too much of the video because it wouldn't match. It just kind of plays out on Michael's face in the most delightful way, like you really believe it. Yeah, you do. Are you ready for one of the most amazing commanding scenes of someone talking and just cutting up a piece of newspaper? Mesmerizing. I watched it three times in a row.
I wrote mesmerizing. Look what I wrote. I was mesmerized by the scene. I'm showing Jenna my paper, you guys. Joe Bennett is going to arrive and she is coming in hot. Oh, yeah. Yeah. She comes in with two lawyers and her dogs.
Mm-hmm. It's a surprise visit, no one was expecting her. And she goes on to explain that the newspaper has run a story about Saber's cheap foreign printers attacking innocent Americans. And while she's saying all of this, she's moving around the room. She's getting a pair of scissors. She's cutting the article as she has this dialogue. One of my favorite moments is when Kevin was like, I think I know what happened.
And she goes, I don't think you do. And then he goes, no, I'm thinking I don't. I know I loved that too. But she's doing so much action while having all of this different emotion. It reminded me of that scene in Secret Santa, when Michael had to go from Santa to Jesus all in one moment with his clothing. Well we had a fan question from Ann S. in Zurich, Switzerland. Who said, can you explain Joe's insane choice to walk all the way over to Angela's desk
to grab a glue stick, to glue the newspaper article to the picture of the office instead of using tape? I looked in the script and all of this stage direction is meticulously outlined within the dialogue. There is like this whole silent play that is scripted out and I thought I would read it. Oh, great. And then I have a little tidbit about when she comes to my desk.
Ooh. All right. Here's what it said in the script. Now mind you, within all of this, there's also dialogue. Right. You're just reading the stage directions. Yes. Joe enters with a couple of well-dressed lawyers.
People are surprised. Joe pulls out a copy of the Times Tribune off Jim's desk and casually flips through it. Joe points to an article titled, Sabre Defends Printers. As Joe speaks, she walks over to Dwight's desk and grabs a pair of scissors. It looks like he might say something but swallows. Joe methodically cuts out the article. Some people nervously chuckle.
Joe slowly carries the article toward accounting, dropping the scissors on Jim's desk as she walks. Dwight is about to grab his scissors. Jim pulls them just out of his reach. Dwight is furious. Joe starts rummaging over the tops of Oscar, Angela, and Kevin's desk looking for something. Finally, she finds it on Angela's desk, a glue stick. Joe walks in a circle toward Michael's office while rubbing glue on the back of the article.
Joe slams the article onto Pam's painting. People look a little scared. Pam looks to Jim like, what the F? Dwight smiles smugly at Pam, like, that's what you get. That was all in the script. Yeah. And I remember us rehearsing it, Jenna. We rehearsed all of this because it was like a one-act play and Kathy had to walk around
the room and engage with all of us. I thought it was great when I rewatched it because you really feel her presence amongst all the workers, the way they staged her walking through the bullpen. But here's what I wanted to share. Here's my tidbit. If you go to three minutes, six seconds, that's when Joe crosses to Angela's desk for the glue stick. And this was the moment in rehearsal when Kathy Bates walked over to my desk and I was really
cold and I had my heater cranked and it had been cranked all morning and she said, it's like the Sahara over here and I'll never forget it. I wrote about it in our book, The Office BFFs, because with my foot went under the desk to try to turn my heater off and I was so embarrassed, I was like, oh no, Kathy Bates. My desk area is so hot. As soon as I rewatched it, I was like, that was a time. Yeah. I wondered if that was the time.
Well, at the end of all of this, Michael is trying to tell Joe, listen, nobody in our office spoke to the press. It wasn't anyone here. But of course, Phyllis knows that it was Andy. Yeah. And she's kind of like Andy. You better say it was you. Come on.
嗯，在这集的最后，迈克尔试图告诉乔，听着，我们办公室里没有人跟记者说话。不是这里的任何人。但菲利斯当然知道那是安迪。是的。而且她有点像是安迪。你最好承认是你干的。得了吧。
And Andy threatens her with such like intensity. I know. He said he will break her glasses, right, and poke them in her eyeball or something. What'd he say? Yeah. You know, the little nubs of your glasses that sit on your nose, there's a name for him and he says he's going to break them off and poke them in her eyes. That's hardcore.
而安迪威胁她的语气真是太激烈了。我知道。他说他要打碎她的眼镜，对吧，然后戳进她的眼球什么的。他刚说了什么？是啊。你知道，你眼镜上架在鼻子上的那两个小鼻垫，它们有个名字，他说他要把它们掰下来，然后戳进她的眼睛里。这太狠了。
Well, he has a talking head where he explains that he is no whistleblower. In fact, generations of Bernard's have made their money by silencing whistleblowers. In fact, Woody Guthrie wrote a song about them. For those of you who don't know who Woody Guthrie is, he was, by all accounts on the Internet and people who love folk music, one of the most significant figures in American folk music, he was, quote, a poet of the people. His songs captured the heart of hard economic times and war. One of his songs you might all know is, This Land is Your Land, This Land is Your Land,
嗯，他有一个面对镜头的独白，在独白中他解释说他不是告密者。事实上，伯纳德家族世世代代都是通过让告密者闭嘴来发财的。事实上，伍迪·格思里还为他们写过一首歌。对于那些不知道伍迪·格思里是谁的人来说，根据网上的各种记载和热爱民谣音乐的人的说法，他是美国民谣音乐中最重要的人物之一，他被誉为“人民的诗人”。他的歌捕捉到了艰难经济时期和战争的核心。你们可能都知道他的其中一首歌，这片土地是你的土地，这片土地是你的土地，
This Land is My Land, you know that one. And incidentally, he was born today. What? In 1912, he was born on July 14th, which is the day we're recording this. That is crazy. I know, I thought so too. We got some mail from Barrett G in Arkansas who said, Have y'all heard the awesome song someone made from that snippet that Andy sang about his family being whistleblowers?
这片土地是我的土地，你们都知道那首歌。顺便说一句，他就是今天出生的。什么？他在1912年出生，出生于7月14日，也就是我们录制这一天。太疯狂了。我知道，我也是这么想的。我们收到了来自阿肯色州巴雷特·G的一封邮件，他说，大家有没有听过有人用安迪唱的关于他家是告密者的那个片段改编的超棒歌曲？
It's actually really good. No, I haven't. I found it. It's by someone named Stormlight on SoundCloud. Let's hear it. From ashes they rose up, from nothing they came. From utter damnation, Bernard was their name. The shame of their past drove them near the insane,
其实真的很好听。不，我还没听过。我找到了。那是SoundCloud上一个叫Stormlight的人创作的。我们来听听看。他们从灰烬中崛起，他们从虚无中走来。从彻底的诅咒中，伯纳德是他们的姓氏。他们过去的耻辱让他们近乎疯狂，
Wearing all of it crumbled while others they blame. Desperate for money, but with nothing to show, They stooped to the lowest a person could go. We'll rule with the ones who will tell what they know, We'll make sure they sleep with the fishes below. Oh, Mr. Bernard, Mr. Bernard, who have you silenced today? Oh, Mr. Bernard, Mr. Bernard, how will you make them pay? I love the idea that the Bernard family are notorious for silencing people who are trying
把这一切都穿在身上，当别人在责怪时，它却崩溃了。渴望金钱，却一无所有，他们沦落到一个人的最低点。我们要和那些知道内情的人一起统治，我们要确保他们和底下的鱼儿一起睡觉。哦，伯纳德先生，伯纳德先生，你今天让谁闭嘴了？哦，伯纳德先生，伯纳德先生，你将如何让他们付出代价？我喜欢这个设定，伯纳德家族以让那些试图
to do the right thing. He's like, there's no way I can be a whistleblower because we are silenced whistleblowers. Yeah. Well, I love that song. My gosh, what a beautiful voice. It goes on and on. It's really, really a good song parody.
做正确事情的人闭嘴而闻名。他说，我绝不可能是告密者，因为我们是让告密者闭嘴的人。是的。嗯，我很喜欢那首歌。天哪，多么动听的声音。这首歌没完没了。它真的是一首非常非常棒的恶搞歌曲。
It's really excellent. Well, here's a little tidbit from Warren and Halstead and also Randy because Jenna, you always reach out to Randy and they said the song was not in the script. Randy said that Paul pitched the lyrics on the day and Warren and Halstead said Jenna Edd had such a great talent for coming up with a tune and being able to make up a song and they could really rely on him and so they found this on the day. That's amazing. They put the lyrics and then Edd just sort of sang a melody and there it was.
真的很棒。嗯，这里有个来自沃伦和霍尔斯特德以及兰迪的小八卦，因为珍娜，你总是联系兰迪，他们说这首歌不在剧本里。兰迪说保罗是在当天即兴想出了歌词，而沃伦和霍尔斯特德说珍娜·埃德在想出曲调和即兴创作歌曲方面有着非凡的天赋，他们真的很依赖他，所以他们是在当天发现了这一点。这太神奇了。他们写好了歌词，然后埃德就哼出一段旋律，就这么成了。
There it was. See, if you gave me lyrics, my melody would be so awful. Oh, I feel like I only have one melody and it's like that whenever I improvise any song and it's the same and it's not great. It's like sitting here talking to Jenna. Exactly. Exactly. Edd is just an amazing musician.
就这么成了。你看，如果你把歌词交给我，我的旋律会难听得要命。哦，我觉得我好像只有一种旋律，而且每当我即兴创作任何歌曲时都是那样的，而且都一样，也不怎么好。就像坐在这里跟珍娜说话一样。没错。没错。埃德简直是个了不起的音乐家。
Well, he's a songwriter in my life too, so it makes sense. Well, Joe is determined to get to the bottom of this. She's going to find out who that whistleblower is. She has an amazing talking head where she talks about when her mom worked as a prison guard and something went missing, to find the guilty party, she would ask everyone what they would do as punishment to the person who stole, right? And if they said, oh, you got to go hard on them, she knew they were innocent. And if they said, you know, maybe they had a reason, blah, blah, that's whose rectum
嗯，他也是我生活中的词曲创作者，所以这说得通。嗯，乔决心要查个水落石出。她要找出那个告密者是谁。她有一段精彩的面对镜头独白，她在里面谈到当她的妈妈作为监狱看守时有东西不见了，为了找出罪魁祸首，她会问每个人，如果对那个偷东西的人进行惩罚，他们会怎么做，对吧？如果他们说，哦，你必须对他们严惩不贷，她就知道他们是无辜的。而如果他们说，你知道，也许他们有理由，巴拉巴拉的，那他们的直肠
would have been searched. Her delivery on that line, that was the Anasade check, is so good. It's like brilliant comedic delivery. Because she puts nothing on it. She puts nothing on it. She never ever, as a performer, it looks like she's trying too hard. It's just effortless and I love it. I do have a random background check during this talking head.
就要被搜查了。她对那句台词的演绎，也就是安娜赛德的梗，太棒了。这简直是绝妙的喜剧表演。因为她演得很自然，一点也不着痕迹。她从来没有、作为表演者，从不让人觉得她用力过猛。一切都是那么游刃有余，我太喜欢了。在这段面对镜头独白期间，我确实进行了一次随机的背景盘查。
But anyone else out there, notice, how much unopened mail is at Dunder Mifflin? Lady, I actually did. There were three enormous bins of unopened mail just sitting there. I'm so confused by the mail system at Dunder Mifflin. Yeah. The cart that never moves? Yeah. But sometimes moves, but really never moves.
但是还有没有其他人注意到，邓德米夫林有多少未拆封的邮件？天哪，我其实注意到了。那里有三大箱未拆封的邮件就那样堆着。我对邓德米夫林的邮件系统感到非常困惑。是啊。那个从来不动的推车？是啊。但有时会动，可实际上从来没动过。
We don't have a mail room. No. At Dunder Mifflin, I don't understand if that's outgoing mail, I don't understand if it's incoming mail, I don't understand how it's distributed. I know. Well, apparently it just sits there by the conference room. The next thing Joe is going to do is bring Michael into the conference room and ask what they should do when they find the whistleblower.
我们没有收发室。没有。在邓德米夫林，我搞不懂那是寄出的邮件，还是收到的邮件，我也不明白它是怎么分发的。我知道。嗯，显然它就那样放在会议室旁边。乔接下来要做的是把迈克尔带进会议室，并问他们找到告密者后应该怎么做。
Yeah. She's starting her interrogation. Well, Michael says they should just ship him off to Montego Bay where they keep all of Al Qaeda. Joe gives a look to camera in that moment. That is so good. Well, here's an interesting tidbit about that scene. Halstead shared that at this time on the show, they were interviewing a new writer, Amelie
是的。她开始审问了。嗯，迈克尔说他们应该直接把他送到蒙特哥湾，那是他们关押所有基地组织成员的地方。乔在那一刻向镜头看了一眼。太棒了。嗯，这里有一个关于那个场景的有趣八卦。霍尔斯特德分享说，在节目的这个时候，他们正在面试一位新编剧，阿梅利
Gillette, who was a very funny AV club writer. All the writers were big fans of her, and she visited Set the day they were filming the scene between Joe and Michael in the conference room. It was her first time on a television set, and Halstead said they wanted to give her a feel for what it would be like to work on the show. So she stood in the corner in the conference room with Vada and Halstead and Paul Lieberstein. That was her job interview. Her job interview was great.
吉莱特，她是一位非常有趣的《影音俱乐部》编剧。所有的编剧都是她的超级粉丝，在她拍摄乔和迈克尔在会议室里的那个场景的当天，她来到了片场。这是她第一次来到电视剧片场，霍尔斯特德说他们想让她感受一下在剧组工作是什么样的。所以她和瓦达、霍尔斯特德以及保罗·利伯斯坦一起站在会议室的角落里。那是她的工作面试。她的工作面试太棒了。
We're going to chitchat with you. Would you like a little tour of the set? And then they brought her down to a conference room with Steve Carell and Kathy Bates. I know. Was she dying? I know. Halstead said they just wanted to give her a feel of what working on the show would be like.
我们要跟你闲聊。你想参观一下片场吗？然后他们把她带到了一个有史蒂夫·卡瑞尔和凯西·贝茨的会议室。我知道。她当时快激动死了吗？我知道。霍尔斯特德说，他们只是想让她感受一下在剧组工作是什么样的。
But then the next year when she joined the staff, she told everyone how crazy it was to suddenly be on the set of the show that she had seen for so many years and then only be feet, just a mere feet away from an Oscar award-winning actor, Kathy Bates, as she had this heated scene with Steve Carell. And Halstead said, in retrospect, I guess that is quite the introduction. I mean, my gosh, that is bonkers. When we reached out to Warren and Halstead, Halstead reached out to Amelie because he was like, I remember you were there that day.
但后来第二年她加入剧组时，她告诉所有人，突然来到她看了这么多年的节目的片场，然后距离荣获奥斯卡奖的演员凯西·贝茨只有几英尺远，甚至就几英尺的距离，看着她和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔进行这场激烈的对戏，这种感觉是多么疯狂。霍尔斯特德说，事后想想，我想这确实是一个相当特别的介绍。我的天哪，这太荒谬了。当我们联系沃伦和霍尔斯特德时，霍尔斯特德联系了阿梅利，因为他说，我记得你那天也在场。
And Amelie also shared this. She said it was completely bonkers to be in the same room with Steve Carell and Kathy Bates. All I could think about was telling my parents about it because they were huge Fried Green Tomatoes fans. And when I told my dad I met Kathy Bates, he said, did you tell her we love Fried Green Tomatoes? And I was like, no, it didn't come up that my parents love that movie.
阿梅利也分享了这一点。她说，能和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔和凯西·贝茨共处一室简直太荒谬了。我脑子里想的只有把这件事告诉我的父母，因为他们是《油炸绿西红柿》的超级粉丝。当我告诉爸爸我遇到了凯西·贝茨时，他说，你告诉她我们很喜欢《油炸绿西红柿》吗？然后我说，没有，我爸妈喜欢这部电影这事儿根本没提起来。
I think it's so sweet. And she said she was fangirling the whole time. That is so sweet. Well, let's take a break because when we come back, Nick, the IT guy, is looking on everyone's computers. Yeah. And Dwight is going to put him in a patchy percussion hold, which I looked up and it's not real.
我觉得这太甜了。她说她全程都在秒变小粉丝。这太甜了。好吧，我们休息一下吧，因为当我们回来时，IT男尼克正在检查每个人的电脑。是的。而德怀特要对他施展帕奇打击固，我查了一下，那根本不是真的。
Yeah, thanks. So far, so good. Fine. We'll be back. All right, we are back. And like we said, Nick, the IT guy asked Dwight if he can look at his computer and he reveals that he's checking everyone's hard drives for information on the leak. I have never seen Kevin take off so fast.
好吧，谢谢。目前一切顺利。好吧。我们要回去了。好了，我们回来了。就像我们说的，IT男尼克问德怀特他是否可以查看他的计算机，然后他透露他正在检查每个人的硬盘以寻找泄密的信息。我从来没见过凯文跑得这么快。
Well, he sprints to his computer. He likes running. He's a runner. Yeah. Mm-hmm. You know, I was talking to Nelson because this is such a great scene. And I did ask him, I was like, you know, what is one of your favorite memories? And I was like, which scene is he going to pick?
嗯，他冲向他的电脑。他喜欢跑步。他是个跑步者。是的。嗯哼。你知道的，我当时在和纳尔逊聊天，因为这真是一个绝妙的场景。我确实问过他，我说，你知道，你最美好的回忆之一是什么？然后我说，他会选哪一个场景呢？
He's had some good ones. What do you share with me? I was totally surprised by and I wanted you guys to hear it. One memory that I definitely cherish is when I was shooting this episode, the whistleblower. I knew it was my last episode. It was a very bittersweet thing for me. I had taken another job opportunity, you know, to be the lead on a different TV show. But I had a lot of mixed emotions about it because as I said, the office is my favorite
他拍过一些不错的场景。你跟我分享了什么？我完全感到惊讶，而且我想让你们听听。我绝对珍视的一个回忆，就是当我正在拍摄这一集《告密者》的时候。我知道这是我的最后一集。对我来说这是一个非常苦乐参半的事情。你知道的，我接受了另一个工作机会，去一部不同的电视剧里担任主角。但我对此有很多复杂的感情，正如我所说，办公室是我最喜欢的
show and I was really heartbroken to be leaving. So I was a pretty emotional that morning and I'm in there in the makeup trailer looking at my lines and Zach Woods pops in and Zach Woods who plays Gabe on the show, of course. And I was blown away. I was like, Zach, and just for a little bit of context here. I went to college with Zach. We were in the same graduating class. We went to NYU together.
节目，我要离开真的让我心碎。所以那天早上我情绪相当激动，我坐在化妆车里看着台词，扎克·伍兹突然探头进来。扎克·伍兹当然就是在剧中扮演盖布的演员。我当时惊呆了。我说，扎克，为了交代一点背景。我和扎克一起上大学。我们在同一个毕业班。我们一起去了纽约大学。
I was in the drama school. I got a degree in acting and he was not in the drama school. He got a regular useful degree. And look, I knew he performed and he did UCB and he was so funny. He's an incredible performer, but I had no idea. He was a professional actor. This is the first time I've seen him since college. I was like, Zach, what the hell are you doing here, man?
我在戏剧学校。我拿到了表演学位，而他不在戏剧学校。他拿到了一个正经且有用的学位。听着，我知道他进行过表演，他也去过UCB（即兴喜剧剧团），他太搞笑了。他是一位令人难以置信的表演者，但我完全不知道。他是一名专业演员。这是我自大学毕业以来第一次见到他。我说，扎克，你到底在这里干什么，老兄？
That was quite a shock for me. If you just imagine one of your friends popping into your job and being like, oh, I work here now. That's insane. I know. And also, you guys, again, this was a time before Instagram, before you knew what everyone's life was. Yeah.
这对我来说是个不小的打击。如果你想象一下，你的某个朋友突然闯进你的工作场所，然后说，哦，我现在在这里上班。这太疯狂了。我知道。而且，各位，再次说明，这是一个在Instagram出现之前、在你了解每个人的生活是怎样的之前的时代。是的。
You could honestly be surprised by running into someone. This is very similar to you walking over to accounting and Oscar sitting there. 100%. Well, I love that we were his first acting job. I love that when he left us, then it was because he was going to be the lead in another show. Yeah. So he went on to have pretty big roles on Veep and New Girl and Black-ish.
你真的会因为偶遇某人而感到惊讶。这非常类似于你走到会计部，而奥斯卡正坐在那里。百分之百。嗯，我很高兴我们是他的第一份表演工作。我很高兴当他离开我们时，那是因为他要去另一部剧里当主角了。是的。所以他后来在《副总统》、《杰茜驾到》和《黑人当道》中出演了相当重要的角色。
And in fact, Angela, we got a fan question from Sierra E. in Silver Spring, Maryland and Deborah J. in Massachusetts. Can we please talk about the office's connections to New Girl? Oh, yeah. Angela, Oscar, Kate, and Nelson Franklin have all been on both the office and New Girl. Angela, what was it like working on New Girl? It was such a blast. I had a recurring role.
事实上，安吉拉，我们收到了来自马里兰州银泉市的西拉·E和马萨诸塞州的黛博拉·J的粉丝提问。我们能聊聊《办公室》和《杰茜驾到》之间的联系吗？哦，是的。安吉拉、奥斯卡、凯特和纳尔逊·富兰克林都出演过《办公室》和《杰茜驾到》。安吉拉，在《杰茜驾到》工作是什么感觉？太好玩了。我有一个常驻角色。
I was a school teacher where Zoe's character also taught the same school. We had so many fun scenes. I also had some really great scenes with Damon. And that cast was so fun. And also, the writers, it really felt familiar to me, like the office, where you would do a scene, you would get it scripted. Maybe if you had an idea, you could pitch it, you know? I loved every second of being on that show.
我是一名学校老师，佐伊的角色也在同一所学校教书。我们有很多有趣的场景。我和达蒙也有一些非常棒的对戏。那个演员阵容太有趣了。而且，编剧们，这真的让我感到很熟悉，就像《办公室》一样，你会拍一场戏，你会拿到剧本。也许如果你有什么想法，你可以提出来，你知道吗？我喜欢在那部剧里的每一秒钟。
It was just great fun. And I'm still in touch with some of the cast members. Here's one memory, though, that sticks with me. And it's not from one of the regular cast members. I was leaving one day. I had worked a half day. As I was leaving the soundstage, Josh Gad was walking in. He was doing a part as well.
真的太有趣了。而且我至今仍与一些演员保持着联系。不过，有一个回忆一直留在我脑海里。而且这不是来自常规演员之一。有一天我要离开了。我上了半天班。当我离开摄影棚时，乔什·盖德正走进来。他也在剧里演一个角色。
And we met sort of in the parking lot. And we were like, oh, my gosh, how are you? And we chit-chatted. How are things going? And he said, oh, I just got this really cool project. I'm pretty excited about I'm going to be a snowman. I'm going to be the voice of a snowman in the movie. Oh, my gosh.
我们在停车场附近碰面了。我们当时说，哦，天哪，你好吗？然后我们闲聊起来。最近怎么样？他说，哦，我刚接了一个超级酷的项目。我挺兴奋的，我要演一个雪人。我要在一部电影里为雪人配音。哦，天哪。
It was frozen. And he had just gotten the job. And he was talking to me about it. And I was like, I remember thinking, oh, that's so cool. You know, that could be really cool. It's frozen. Oh, my gosh. He's Olaf.
那是《冰雪奇缘》。他刚刚得到这份工作。他正在跟我谈论这个。我就记得当时想，哦，太酷了。你知道，这真的很酷。那是《冰雪奇缘》。哦，天哪。他是雪宝。
He's Olaf. Wow. Wow. Well, now we're going to move into Michael's office, where Angela Oscar and Phyllis are trying to reason with Michael. They're saying everyone knows it was Andy. And everyone shouldn't have to suffer because of it. And Michael just needs to say it was Andy.
他是雪宝。哇。哇。好吧，现在我们要走进迈克尔的办公室，安吉拉、奥斯卡和菲利斯在那里试图劝说迈克尔。他们说大家都知道那是安迪。大家不应该为此而遭受连累。迈克尔只需要承认那是安迪干的就行了。
And you all are wearing pink and purple. It's like you had a club called throw Andy under the bus and the dress code is pink and purple. Yeah. The next scene is between Dwight and Joe in the conference room. I love this scene. It has one of my absolute favorite lines in the whole episode. Dwight says, I don't want to waste your time and I wouldn't dare waste mine.
而且你们都穿着粉红色和紫色的衣服。这就像你们建立了一个名叫“把安迪扔到车轮底下”的俱乐部，而着装要求就是粉红色和紫色。是的。下一个场景是德怀特和乔在会议室里的对手戏。我太喜欢这个场景了。它有整集里我最绝对最喜欢的台词之一。德怀特说，我不想浪费你的时间，我也绝不敢浪费我自己的时间。
It's like one of my favorite lines. I like want to say that in a meeting. He says he didn't do it and he doesn't know who exactly did, but he has a list of people she should fire. Well, we got a fan question from Mary M. in Canada asking about that list. Here is what Mary had to say. Number one, whose handwriting do you think that is? Is it Reigns?
这就像我最喜欢的台词之一。我很想在会议上说这句话。他说他没干这事，他也不知道到底是谁干的，但他有一份她应该解雇的人的名单。嗯，我们收到了来自加拿大玛丽·M的粉丝提问，询问关于那份名单的问题。以下是玛丽想问的：
Bill Shays? Number two, what are the numbers that correspond to each name? Michael has a five, Jim has a one, Creed has a four. What does this mean? And finally, what's up with the order of this list? Why is Michael first? Seems like whoever wrote this list just looked around the room and wrote an order who they saw.
第一，你认为那是谁的笔迹？是雷恩斯的吗？比尔·谢斯的？第二，与每个名字相对应的数字是什么？迈克尔是5，吉姆是1，克里德是4。这是什么意思？最后，这份名单的顺序是怎么回事？为什么迈克尔排在第一位？看起来写这份名单的人只是环顾了一下房间，然后按照他们看到的人的顺序写下来的。
I really need an explanation. Well, Mary, guess what? I was going crazy about this list too. I was very curious. First of all, Jenna, there's no way that is Reigns handwriting. No, it didn't look like Reigns. Reigns has chicken scratch. It's probably Phil Shays.
我真的需要一个解释。嗯，玛丽，你猜怎么着？我为了这张名单也快疯了。我非常好奇。首先，珍娜，那绝对不可能是雷恩斯的笔迹。不，看起来不像雷恩斯的。雷恩斯的字像鸡爪抓的一样。那可能是菲尔·谢斯的。
Probably. But Mary, the numbers. I was like, what is this list? What are these numbers? I took a picture of the screen. I zoomed in on them. Mary, this is what I caught. Michael Scott, five, Jim Halpert, one, Pam Halpert, three, Phyllis Vance, two, Andy Bernard,
很可能是。但玛丽，那些数字。我当时想，这是什么名单？这些数字是什么？我拍下了屏幕照片。我把它们放大了。玛丽，这就是我捕捉到的信息：
one, Stanley Hudson, two, Creed Bratton, four, Meredith Palmer, three, Angela Martin, two, Kevin Malone, one. Then I saw Oscar, but I couldn't make Oscar and Darryl and Kelly. I could see their names, but Joe's sleeve was blocking it. So that's as far as the list I could see. Everyone is rated between one and five. Is it their DEF CONS? That's the only thing I know that you rate one through five at this point.
迈克尔·斯科特，5；吉姆·帕尔特，1；帕姆·帕尔特，3；菲利斯·万斯，2；安迪·伯纳德，1；斯坦利·哈德森，2；克里德·布拉顿，4；梅雷迪思·帕尔默，3；安吉拉·马丁，2；凯文·马龙，1。然后我看到了奥斯卡，但我看不清奥斯卡、达雷尔和凯利。我能看到他们的名字，但乔的袖子把它挡住了。这就是我能看到的名单的全部。每个人都被评定在1到5之间。这是他们的防卫等级吗？据我所知，这是目前唯一用1到5级来评定的东西。
No, but I went digging in the shooting draft because I had to know, guess what I found? What? The answer. I can't believe you found the answer to this. Okay. In the shooting draft, the scene read like this. Dwight, I don't want to waste your time. I wouldn't dare waste mine.
不，但我去拍摄初稿里深挖了，因为我必须知道，你猜我发现了什么？什么？答案。我真不敢相信你找到了这个问题的答案。好的。在拍摄初稿中，那个场景是这样写的：
It wasn't me. People who misuse products don't deserve to will to saber. Now I don't know exactly who did it, but I suggest you fire the following people. Dwight hands Joe some papers. Joe says, there's a lot of people on this list. Dwight says, you can fire them in waves. That's what the numbers next to the names are. The waves.
德怀特，我不想浪费你的时间。我绝不敢浪费我自己的时间。不是我干的。滥用产品的人不配拥有萨博车。现在我不知道到底是谁干的，但我建议你解雇以下人员。德怀特递给乔一些文件。乔说，这个名单上的人很多。德怀特说，你可以分批解雇他们。这就是名字旁边的数字所代表的意思。分批。
Wow. It's a wave number one and then wave number two. So now look back on the list. Joe's getting fired first per Dwight's list, Jim, Andy, and Kevin. Of course, I can't see Oscar, Darrell, and Kelly. Second wave would have been Angela, Stanley, and Phyllis. Third wave would have been Pam, all by myself, and Meredith. And then the fourth wave would have been Creed, and the final wave would have been Michael.
哇。这是第一批，然后是第二批。所以现在回头看那份名单。根据德怀特的名单，吉姆、安迪和凯文是要被第一批解雇的。当然，我看不见奥斯卡、达雷尔和凯利。第二批是安吉拉、斯坦利和菲利斯。第三批是帕姆（孤零零一个人）和梅雷迪思。然后第四批是克里德，最后一批是迈克尔。
So even though he's number one on the list, he's number five in the wave. This is the weirdest list. I love that you got an answer to that. I know. It was so random. Well, also in this scene, Joe asks if Dwight's being smart about his money. He's had a good year. And she says that he really should have his money turn into more money and he should buy
所以尽管他在名单上排第一，但在批次里他排第五。这是最诡异的名单。我很高兴你得到了这个答案。我知道。太随机了。嗯，同样在这个场景中，乔询问德怀特他的财务状况是否明智。他今年过得不错。她说他真的应该让自己的钱生出更多的钱，他应该买
property. Yes. That's what a smart person would do. Well, Warren and Halstead shared that when they had the idea that Dwight should buy the building, they needed a reason why he would decide to buy the building. And they loved this idea that Joe would plant the seed just by giving him some simple advice to buy property. Yeah.
房产。是的。聪明人都会这么做。嗯，沃伦和霍尔斯特德分享说，当他们萌生出让德怀特买下这栋大楼的想法时，他们需要一个理由来解释他为什么会决定买下这栋大楼。他们很喜欢这个想法，即乔只需要给他一些买房的简单建议，就能埋下这颗种子。是的。
So this was their way of planting that little cliffhanger, which is going to eventually pay off brilliantly. I mean, this little thing is going to grow into work bus. I know. Well, Michael is going to ask Andy if he talked to the press and Andy is going to, I mean, go overboard swearing on his parents' grave who aren't even dead yet, that he did not do it. And then he's going to cast some suspicion on Daryl.
所以这是他们埋下那个小悬念的方式，这个悬念最终将带来惊人的回报。我的意思是要，这个小小的举动最终会发展成工作巴士。我知道。嗯，迈克尔要问安迪他是否跟记者谈过，而安迪则会，我的意思是，极其夸张地以他甚至还没死去的父母的坟墓发誓，说他绝对没有这么做。然后他要将一些怀疑引向达雷尔。
I was very surprised that Michael confronted Andy with his office door open. Oh. The whole time I kept thinking, I feel like Joe could kind of hear this very easily or just right around the little corner. I also noticed that both Dwight and Jim were not at their deaths in the background of this scene. And I think part of that was to create a line of vision into Daryl's office because they could see.
我很惊讶迈克尔开着办公室门跟安迪对质。哦。我一直在想，我觉得乔很容易就能听到这个，或者就在那个小拐角附近。我也注意到，在这个场景的背景中，德怀特和吉姆都不在他们的工位上。我认为部分原因是为了营造一条通往达雷尔办公室的视线，因为他们能看见。
They move right in there and then Michael moves in there. Daryl is going to confess that he actually did tell someone about the printer's catching on fire and it turns out that she works as a copy editor at the Tribune. I know. He was chatty at the bar. He was trying to hit on her. Yeah. I know Michael doesn't know what to do because he swore up and down that none of his employees
他们直接搬到那里去了，然后迈克尔也搬到那里去了。达雷尔将承认他确实跟某人谈起过打印机着火的事，结果证明那个人在论坛报担任文案编辑。我知道。他在酒吧里很健谈。他当时想搭讪她。是的。我知道迈克尔不知道该怎么办，因为他信誓旦旦地保证他的员工里没有人
did this. And now he's discovered that maybe they did. Meanwhile, Joe is talking with Toby. I loved this so much. This scene delighted me. She says, you know, we know it wasn't you. We didn't find anything on your computer except his novel. His mystery novel.
做过这事。现在他发现也许他们真的做了。与此同时，乔正在和托比谈话。我太喜欢这个了。这个场景让我感到无比欢乐。她说，你知道的，我们知道不是你。我们在你的计算机上什么也没找到，除了他的小说。他的悬疑小说。
And she's got a few notes for him to which he hears her out and then says, write your own damn novel. He's talking head, but Warren and Halstead shared something kind of fun with us. They said earlier in the season was the very first mention of the Scranton Strangler. And in this final episode of season six, when Joe finds Toby's novel, after reading it, she says that the protagonist needs to help in hiding a murder, which appears to leave Toby irritated and early egg if you think Toby might be the Scranton Strangler. And Joe indirectly helped Toby figure out how to cover his tracks.
她为他准备了一些意见，托比听取了她的意见，然后说，写你自己的烂小说去吧。这是他的面对镜头独白，但沃伦和霍尔斯特德跟我们分享了一些挺有趣的事。他们说在本季的早些时候，第一次提到了斯克兰顿扼杀者。而在第六季的最后一集中，当乔发现托比的小说时，在读过之后，她说主角需要在藏匿谋杀案方面提供帮助，这似乎让托比感到恼火，如果你认为托比可能是斯克兰顿扼杀者的话，这显得有些草木皆兵。而乔间接地帮助托比弄清楚了如何掩盖自己的行踪。
Very interesting. There really is a lot of evidence pointing to Toby. I know. Well, in his talking head where he says, write your own damn novel, I have a background catch. Did you see the kind of like green foam dog bone thing on his desk that says Toby's troops? Yes. Yeah, I looked it up. What is it?
非常有趣。确实有很多证据指向托比。我知道。嗯，在他那段说“写你自己的烂小说去吧”的面对镜头独白中，我注意到了一个背景细节。你看到他桌上那个类似于绿色泡沫狗骨头、上面写着“托比的部队”的东西了吗？看到了。是的，我查了一下。那是什么？
What is it? It says on there also. It says Toby Hanna Federal Credit Union. There's a website, but it's not working anymore. But I found a post online that says Toby Hanna is a real federal credit union in Scranton, Pennsylvania. And in the post, this person says a friend of mine that lives there told me the credit union used to call its members troops.
那是什么？上面还写着。上面写着“托比汉娜联邦信用合作社”。有一个网站，但已经不能用了。但我找到了一个网上帖子，上面说托比汉娜是宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿的一个真实的联邦信用合作社。在那篇帖子中，这个人说住在那里的一位朋友告诉我，该信用合作社过去称其成员为部队。
Oh my gosh, Phil Shea got that from the Chamber of Commerce for sure. For sure. And he put it on Toby's desk because his name is Toby. Very funny. Well, we have another whistleblower. I know. Apparently everyone who works here is real chatty. I love doing this scene.
哦，天哪，菲尔·谢斯绝对是从商会那里得到这个灵感的。肯定的。他把它放在托比的桌上，因为他的名字叫托比。太搞笑了。嗯，我们还有另一个告密者。我知道。显然这里工作的每个人都很健谈。我喜欢拍这个场景。
This was a scene of Pam and Jim in the stairwell. This was a stairwell right outside of Randy's office. So that was always fun because I would walk up the stairs and just go chitchat with him when we were, you know, doing different setups. Pam says that she probably leaked the information. And I love her reason why. Yeah, she just needed something interesting to say to this other mom who had been chatting about her travels.
这是帕姆和吉姆在楼梯间的场景。这是兰迪办公室外面的一段楼梯间。所以这总是很有趣，因为当我走上楼梯时，只要我们在进行不同的机位设置，我就会顺便去找他闲聊。帕姆说她可能泄露了信息。我喜欢她这么做的原因。是的，她只是需要跟这位一直在聊她旅行经历的其他妈妈说点有趣的事。
And Pam's like, well, our printers catch on fire. I know. It's so funny. Pam is going to tell Michael now. Oh my gosh, whose mind is going a mile an hour. It really is. We had a fan question from Shea T. in Montana wanting to know if that line was scripted or improvised because it is one of my favorite lines and Steve performed it so well.
然后帕姆就说，嗯，我们的打印机着火了。我知道。太搞笑了。帕姆现在要告诉迈克尔了。哦，天哪，他的脑子转得飞快。确实如此。我们收到了来自蒙大拿州谢伊·T的粉丝提问，想知道那句台词是按剧本演的还是即兴发挥的，因为这是我最喜欢的台词之一，史蒂夫演得太棒了。
Shea, that was scripted. Yeah. It's very funny. And it made me laugh every time Steve said it. Michael is spinning now because there are two whistleblowers. Yes. This is going to lead to an amazing meeting in Meredith's van. I want to break down the hand gestures.
谢伊，那是按剧本演的。是的。非常搞笑。而且每次史蒂夫说出来时都逗得我哈哈大笑。迈克尔现在脑子一片混乱，因为有两个告密者。是的。这将在梅雷迪思的小货车里引发一场精彩的会议。我想分解一下这些手势。
Okay. Okay. Michael is going to walk up to Pam and he points to Pam. He points to himself. Then he points to Meredith and then he pretends to drink something. Then he pretends to drive. Then he points to his wrist. And then he makes the number five and Pam's like, oh my God, I know exactly what he's
好的。好的。迈克尔走向帕姆，他指着帕姆。他指着自己。然后他指着梅雷迪思，接着他假装在喝东西。然后他假装在开车。接着他指着自己的手腕。然后他比划了一个数字5，帕姆就说，哦，天哪，我完全知道他在
saying. Here are the people who are going to meet in the van. It's not just Michael and Pam. It's also Daryl and then suddenly Kelly. Yeah. And Pam says we're not going for yogurt. And Michael says no, Kelly is also a whistleblower. Well while they're sitting in this van and they're discussing who is the whistleblower
说什么了。以下是将在小货车里开会的人。不仅仅是迈克尔和帕姆。还有达雷尔，然后凯利突然也来了。是的。帕姆说我们不是去买酸奶。迈克尔说不，凯利也是个告密者。嗯，当他们坐在小货车里讨论谁是告密者
and what they're going to do, Pam is holding up a bunch of unpaid parking tickets. Daryl holds up a boot. Yeah. You know, that's the thing they put on your tire when you haven't... You have too many parking tickets. You haven't paid your tickets. Or also incidentally, I looked it up if your license has been suspended. Did you know that they're called the Denver Boot because Denver was the first city to
以及他们要做什么时，帕姆举起了一堆未交的停车罚单。达雷尔举起了一个车轮锁。是的。你知道的，那是当你没有……你有太多停车罚单时，他们放在你轮胎上的东西。你没有交罚单。或者顺便说一句，我查了一下，如果你的驾照被吊销了。你知道它们为什么被称为丹佛车轮锁吗，因为丹佛是第一个
use the boot? I didn't know that, but my friend, when I was living here in my twenties, her car got booted. Yeah. I knew people whose car got booted. Yeah. I had to drive her down to the impound lot and she had to pay an enormous fine. Oh yeah.
使用车轮锁的城市？我不知道这一点，但当我二十多岁住在这里时，我的朋友，她的车被锁过。是的。我认识的人车被锁过。是的。我不得不开车送她去扣车场，她不得不支付一大笔罚款。哦，是的。
Yeah. I want to point out, I found it very interesting that Michael called this meeting in Meredith's van and not the Michael Scott Paper Company, which he is still leasing. That's such a good point, lady. I wonder if they wanted to call it in there and Randy Courgette was like, I am not cleaning that out again. Yeah. I'm not moving.
是的。我想指出的是，我觉得很有趣的是迈克尔把这次会议开在了梅雷迪思的小货车里，而不是迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司，他现在还在租着那间办公室。这真是个好点子，lady。我想他们可能想在那里开会，但兰迪·柯代尔说，我才不会再去清扫那地方呢。是的。我不搬。
We just moved everything back in there. Right. I don't have any tapes. I cannot relocate it. How about Meredith's van? Yeah. There's got to be a story there. Some other place.
我们才刚把所有东西都搬回来。对。我没有任何录像带。我不能重新安置它。梅雷迪思的小货车怎么样？是的。那里面一定有什么故事。或者其他地方。
Well, Kelly is like, of course she's the leak. She probably tweeted it and this is when she sets up Wolf. Yeah. She said she spends the whole day talking, video chat, Skype, text, Twitter, phone, Wolf. And then we go to Ryan's closet and he's going to tell us what Wolf is. I will never get tired of seeing Ryan in that little closet. No. It's so true.
嗯，凯利觉得，她当然是泄密者。她可能发了推特，这就是她设置Wolf的原因。是的。她说她一整天都在聊天，视频聊天、Skype、发短信、推特、打电话、Wolf。然后我们来到瑞恩的壁橱，他要告诉我们什么是Wolf。看瑞恩待在那个小壁橱里，我永远都不会腻。不。确实如此。
Ryan explains that Wolf is a site he's launching and hopes that it will be the last word in social networking. It basically links up all of your communication portals and he does a demonstration where he sends himself a Wolf, which then gives him a notification on all of his devices at once. Ryan notifies him via intercom, he gets a fax, it pops up on his screen, his phone, like everywhere. It all goes off at once.
瑞恩解释说，Wolf是他正在推出的一款网站，他希望它能成为社交网络界的终极之声。它基本上连接了你所有的通信端口，他做了一个演示，他给自己发送了一条Wolf消息，这随后让他所有的设备同时收到了通知。瑞恩通过对讲机通知自己，他收到了一份传真，它弹出了在他的屏幕上、他的手机上，就像到处都是。所有设备同时响了起来。
Everything goes off. Well, a lot of people wrote in to say this was the first mention of Wolf and it is. Warren and Halstead said that this just started as a one-off joke for this episode. They kind of came up with it in the writer's room, but it is eventually going to become a whole episode in season seven. Yes. They reached out to writer Aaron Schur, because I know he writes the episode Wolf, eventually, right?
所有东西都响了。嗯，很多人写信来说这是第一次提到Wolf，确实如此。沃伦和霍尔斯特德说，这只是这一集的一个一次性笑话。他们是在编剧室里临时想出来的，但它最终将在第七季中成为一整集的内容。是的。他们联系了编剧亚伦·舒尔，因为我知道他最终写了《Wolf》那一集，对吧？
And he said he pitched the name Wolf, but someone else pitched the idea of it. But how he came up with the name was he said Twitter was just starting and he thought the sound a dog makes instead of a bird, if it's funny. Oh yeah. That's good. I like it. Yeah. Randy shared that they had everything rigged to go off at the same time, but that Ellie
他说他提出了Wolf这个名字，但其他人提出了它的构思。他是怎么想出这个名字的，他说当时推特刚开始起步，他觉得狗发出的声音代替鸟儿的叫声，如果这很有趣的话。哦，是的。这很好。我喜欢。是的。兰迪分享说，他们把所有东西都串联起来以便同时触发，但埃莉
does not actually call on the phone. To time that out, they had her just standing off camera to do her line, and then in post-production they put an effect on her voice to make it sound like it was from the phone. Well, I have to point out one thing about Ryan in this scene. He has now officially combined all of his new looks. Did you catch it? It's glasses, suspenders, bow tie, orange watch. Wow.
其实并没有在电话里说话。为了把握好时间，他们让她站在镜头外说出她的台词，然后在后期制作中对她的声音进行了处理，使其听起来像是来自电话。嗯，关于这个场景中的瑞恩，我必须指出一件事。他现在正式把他所有的全新造型组合在一起了。你注意到了吗？是眼镜、背带、领结、橙色手表。哇。
The only thing missing is his hat. It's kind of like he's woofed his wardrobe. Well, if Michael was freaking out that he had two whistleblowers, now his mind is completely blown because he has three whistleblowers. His solution to this is that they just smash all the computers, destroy the evidence. Yes. But really, Pam says, I think you just need to convince Joe to go easy on all of us. And then once we know our jobs are safe, we all confess at once.
唯一缺少的是他的帽子。这感觉就像他把自己的衣柜也用Wolf融合了一样。嗯，如果说迈克尔之前因为有两个告密者而抓狂的话，现在他的脑子彻底炸了，因为他有三个告密者。他的解决方案是，他们直接砸碎所有的计算机，销毁证据。是的。但帕姆说，实际上，我觉得你只需要说服乔对我们大家从轻发落。然后一旦我们知道我们的工作保住了，我们所有人就同时坦白。
So this is going to be the new plan. Meanwhile, Toby is in the break room. His snack is stuck in the vending machine, and he starts doing the thing where you kind of jiggle and try to move the vending machine. Dwight offers to help him, but he gets a call in the middle, and then Toby's stuck just sort of holding up a vending machine. They've tipped it forward. When I saw that, I was like, wait, was that in the script?
所以这将是新计划。与此同时，托比在休息室里。他的零食卡在自动售货机里了，他开始做那种晃动并试图移动自动售货机的事情。德怀特提出要帮他，但他在半途接到了一个电话，然后托比就被迫一个人扶着自动售货机。他们把它向前倾斜了。当我看到那个时，我想，等等，那在剧本里吗？
It had to have been in the script because it's such a big prop move. I couldn't figure out how he was doing it. According to thepromove.com, vending machines weigh between 400 and 900 pounds when they are empty. Wow. And you really can't move them without proper equipment. So I asked Randy Cordray about it. He said that Mike Thompson, our on-set special effects technician, rigged the back of the
那一定在剧本里，因为这是一个很大的道具动作。我当时想不通他是怎么做到这一点的。根据thepromove.com网站的说法，自动售货机在空的时候重量在400到900磅之间。哇。如果没有适当的设备，你真的无法移动它们。所以我问了兰迪·柯代尔关于这回事。他说迈克·汤普森，我们片场的特效技术人员，用一条安全缆绳固定了机器的背面，这条缆绳一直穿过了后面的那堵墙。然后迈克·汤普森就站在墙后面。他说这是个区域，珍娜，我们的午餐桌通常就在这里，我想这大概只有我们才能想象得到，安吉拉，但为了让你知道，迈克就站在那里。他把这根绳子穿过墙。他对其进行了操纵，以便机器可以倾斜到某个特定的角度，但实际上是迈克在承受重量。所以它绝对不会倒下来，那根缆绳拉着它，所以它不可能真正倒在
machine with a safety cable, and it went all the way through that back wall. And then Mike Thompson stood behind there. He said this was the area, Jenna, where our lunch tables usually were, that I guess really is only something we can visualize, Angela, but just so you know, Mike's standing there. He's got this cord through the wall. He had manipulated it so that the machine could tilt at a certain angle, but Mike was actually holding the weight. And so it could never fall, like that cable was holding it so it couldn't actually fall
保罗身上。他们就是这样非常逼真地拍出这一幕的。所以迈克尔要去找乔，他会说，你知道，关于这个告密者，我转念一想，我觉得我们可以让他们工作，让他们进来，他们只需要好好工作就行了。是的，他们完全可以保留他们的工作。然后她说，迈克尔·斯科特，你知道什么？但他就是不告诉她。
on Paul. And that's how they did it very convincingly. So Michael's going to go up to Joe and he's going to be like, you know, on second thought about this whistleblower, I think we make them work, come in here, and they just got to work. Yeah, they get to totally keep their job. And she's like, Michael Scott, what do you know? But he's not going to tell her.
不，她要把他们带进会议室，然后他们进行了一场对峙。他就是不肯告诉她他知道的事。有一个很棒的时刻，她说，迈克尔，说话，说话。然后沙发上的狗叫了一声。我们收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州的埃诺克·N和莎拉·M以及其他人的粉丝提问，他们想知道当乔说“说话”而狗叫时，那是按剧本演的还是即兴发挥的？嗯，我在剧本里没看到这个。我能给你答案，因为沃伦和霍尔斯特德告诉我，狗叫和
No, she's going to bring them into the conference room and they just kind of face off. He will not tell her what he knows. There's a great moment where she says, Michael, speak, speak. And then the dog barks on the couch. We had a fan question from Enoch N and Sarah M from Pennsylvania and others who wanted to know when Joe says, speak and the dog barks, was that scripted or improvised? Well, I did not see it in the script. I have an answer for you because Warren and Halstead told me that the dog barking and
乔说“说话”是他们在当天临时想出来的。对我们来说幸运的是，驯狗师能够让这只狗按口令叫出声来。嗯，我很高兴，因为那是个很棒的包袱。我太喜欢了。兰迪跟我们分享说，扮演狗狗的演员依然是之前的两只大丹犬，加比和吉尼斯。我觉得我认出它们了。是吗？
Joe saying speak were something that they came up with on the day. And luckily for us, the dog trainer was able to get the dog to Hal on command. Well, I'm glad because that was a good bit. I loved it. And Randy shared with us that the same Great Danes as before were our dog actors, Gabby and Guinness. I felt like I recognized them. Did you?
是的。我知道它们还是那两只。你从一大群大丹犬里把加比和吉尼斯挑出来了。我分不清哪只是哪只，但当它们刚进门时，我想，还是那些大丹犬。还是那些大丹犬。嗯，在这场会议结束时，乔邀请迈克尔跟她一起离开，她开车载他去了一个小型机场。
I did. I knew they were the same. You took Gabby and Guinness out of a Great Dane crowd. I don't know which one is which, but when they walked in the door at the very beginning, I thought, same Danes. Same Danes. Well, at the end of this meeting, Joe is going to invite Michael to leave with her and she drives him to a small airport.
我太喜欢迈克尔那种偏执的性格了。他当时说，我和警察局长有个晚宴。他以为乔想干什么？以防她想搞什么鬼名堂，他已经安排好要跟官员们会面了。与此同时，德怀特正准备敲定他的房地产交易，因为他正在买下乔建议的那处房产，但当他在跟他的真实编辑打电话时，他看到了一个牌子。上面写着斯克兰顿商业园区。
I love how paranoid Michael is. He's like, I've got a dinner with Chief of Police. What does he think Joe's up to? Just in case she's up to something shady, he has some plans to meet with officials. Meanwhile, Dwight is getting ready to wrap up his real estate deal because he's buying that property that Joe suggested, but he sees a sign while he's on the phone with his real editor. It says Scranton Business Park.
他有了一个主意。给他一个无法拒绝的出价。实际上是报个超低价。赶紧把它搞定。是的。他要买下这栋大楼。我们收到了来自英国的Ashley S的粉丝提问，当德怀特对斯克兰顿商业园区（即斯劳大道1725号）出价时，这是否是在向以斯劳为背景的英国原版剧集致敬？
He has an idea. Make him an offer they can't refuse. Actually lowball them. Just get it done. Yeah. He's going to buy the building. We had a fan question from Ashley S. in the UK when Dwight makes an offer on the Scranton Business Park, 1725 Slough Avenue, was that a nod to the British show which was set in
是的，确实是的。当然是的。是的，确实是。这一直是我们的地址。它甚至出现在试播集中迈克尔·斯科特的商业名片上。是的。你和我各拿了一张。
Slough? Yes, it was. Of course it was. Yes, it was. That has always been our address. It's even on Michael Scott's business card from the pilot. Yeah. Which you and I both took one.
我们当然拿了。我们当然拿了。是的。兰迪分享说，背景中那个写着“邓德米夫林”的大型商业园区标志，是为了那一幕临时竖起来的，然后很快就被拆掉了。他说我们从来不想引起人们的注意。我们不想在街上挂出一个写着“邓德米夫林的牌子。对。
Of course we did. Of course we did. Yes. Randy shared that that big business park sign in the background that says Dunder Mifflin, that was put up just for that scene and then it was quickly taken down. He said we never wanted to draw attention to ourselves. We did not want to have a sign that said Dunder Mifflin out on the street like that. Right.
回到办公区，盖布已经结束了他的调查。是的。他说根据所有的证据，是安迪干的，大家都表示赞同，尽管吉姆确实试图让安迪感觉好受一些，但安迪却直接把他推到了车轮底下。顺便说一句，盖布的调查做得并不好，因为大卫·华莱士突然出现在一个面对镜头的独白中，他说其实是他干的。他说他从一个老客户那里听说了他们的问题，然后他就立刻开始传播这个消息。
Back in the bullpen, Gabe has concluded his investigation. Yes. He says Andy did it based on all the evidence and everyone agrees, although Jim does try to make Andy feel better but then Andy just throws him under the bus. By the way, Gabe didn't do a very good job investigating because David Wallace pops in for a talking head where he says that he did it. He's like, he heard from an old client about their problems and he immediately started spreading the news.
回到办公区，加布已经结束了他的调查。是的。他说根据所有的证据，安迪是凶手，大家都同意，尽管吉姆试图让安迪感觉好受些，但安迪却把吉姆给出卖了。顺便说一句，加布的调查做得并不好，因为大卫·华莱士在采访中突然出现，说其实是他干的。他就像是，从一个老客户那里听说了他们的麻烦，然后立刻就开始把消息传开了。
But he's not really here to talk about that. He wants to talk about Socket. He only wants to talk about Socket. Speaking of that talking head, Angie, we had a fan catch from Sarah H. and Williamsburg, Virginia, who said, as a dog obsessed person, I always get excited whenever we visit David Wallace's house because he has a dog. But in David's talking head, this is not the same dog as before. David originally had a golden retriever and now it looks like he has a hound mix or a
但他来这里其实不是为了谈这个。他想谈的是索科特。他只想谈索科特。说到那个大头娃娃，安吉，我们收到了来自弗吉尼亚州威廉斯堡的萨拉·H（Sarah H.）的粉丝来信，她说，作为一个痴迷狗狗的人，每当看到我们去大卫·华莱士（David Wallace）家时，我总是会感到很兴奋，因为他养了一只狗。但在大卫的大头特写镜头里，这已经不是以前那只狗了。大卫原本养了一只金毛寻回犬，现在看起来他养了一只猎犬混血或者
pointer of some kind. Sarah says this is not a groundbreaking discovery, but I thought it was kind of fun that the Wallace has got a new dog. Well I have an answer for you, Sarah. I thought I recognized this dog when I watched the episode and I reached out to Warren and he confirmed it. This was Paul Lieberstein's dog. His name was Dude.
某种指示犬。萨拉说这并不是什么惊天大发现，但她觉得华莱士家养了只新狗挺有趣的。好吧，萨拉，我来给你答案。我当时看这集的时候就觉得这只狗眼熟，于是我联系了沃伦，他证实了这一点。这就是保罗·莉伯斯坦（Paul Lieberstein）的狗。它的名字叫“伙计”（Dude）。
Wait, this is Paul's dog in real life? Yes, it's Paul's dog in real life. His name was Dude. He was the sweetest dog. I love that dog. Oh my gosh. He was like one of those big dogs who thinks he's a lap dog. This is so funny because I wrote to Randy about this question and I said, what is this
等等，这是保罗现实生活中的狗？是的，这就是保罗现实生活中的狗。它的名字叫“伙计”。它是最温顺的狗。我太喜欢那只狗了。天哪。它就像那种明明体型巨大，却自认为是个怀抱犬的狗狗。太搞笑了，因为我为了这个问题给兰迪（Randy）写过信，我说，这到底是
dog? Was this Bob Dunn's animal menagerie dog? No. And he said, Jenna, I have no record of this dog. I can't believe it. I don't know who the dog is. It was Dude. Wow.
什么狗？这是鲍勃·邓恩（Bob Dunn）的动物园里的狗吗？不是。他说，珍娜，我对这只狗没有任何记录。我简直不敢相信。我不知道这只狗是谁。它就是“伙计”。哇。
I love it. Well, lady, I think we stay in the bullpen because Nick is going to have such a big scene. Let's let all this play out and then we'll go back to the plane where Michael and Joe are. I like that. Yeah. Nick, the IT guy, he's going to say goodbye to everyone because he's going to Detroit with Teach for America.
我太喜欢了。好吧，各位，我觉得我们还是留在办公区吧，因为尼克（Nick）接下来有一场重头戏。我们先让这些剧情发展完，然后我们再回到迈克尔和乔（Joe）所在的飞机上。我喜欢这样。对。尼克，那个IT男，他要跟每个人告别，因为他要和“为美国而教”（Teach for America）组织去底特律了。
No one can even remember his name, Jenna. I know. And Gabe is like, this is not the time. I am talking about an investigation. I forgot how badly the whole bullpen blows off Nick. Poor guy. He was just trying to say a nice goodbye. I know.
甚至没人记得他的名字，珍娜。我知道。而加布（Gabe）却说，现在不是时候。我在谈论一项调查。我都忘了整个办公区对尼克是多么冷淡和不理睬。可怜的家伙。他只是想好好告别一下。我知道。
Nick is like, you know what? I've kind of had it. I've looked at all your hard drives and he starts revealing all these truths. Yeah. And then he says, and I'll tell you what, Andy is the whistleblower. I saw it. He wrote a note to the press, then he gives everybody the finger and walks out. Yeah.
尼克就好像在说，你知道吗？我真是够了。我看过你们所有人的硬盘了，然后他开始揭露所有这些真相。对。接着他说，我告诉你们吧，安迪就是告密者。我看到了。他给媒体写了一纸便条，然后他向所有人竖起中指，气冲冲地走了。对。
He does a two bird salute on the way out. We had a fan question from Kyle T. in Houston, Texas. Did Nick call out other people that we did not get to see? Yes, Kyle. He did. He has a dig at Jim and Pam that I remember from when we were shooting. Yes. You do.
他在离开的时候竖了双指敬礼。我们收到了来自德克萨斯州休斯顿的凯尔·T（Kyle T.）的粉丝提问。尼克还点名了其他人，但我们没有在正片里看到吗？是的，凯尔。他确实点名了。我对我们当时拍摄时他挖苦吉姆和帕姆的片段记忆犹新。对。你记得。
So I went back to the script and here's your answer. He says to Ryan, you are not a photographer. And he says to Kelly, you are not a size two. Those made the cut. Yeah. Then he would have said to Phyllis, you are sending flirty emails to your stepson Phyllis. And then he says to Pam, while pointing to Phyllis, she thinks your kid is ugly. Then he says to Jim while pointing to Pam, she hates that you can't put up a hammock without
于是我翻回了剧本，这就是你的答案。他对瑞恩说：“你不是摄影师。”他对凯利说：“你不是两号身材。”这些片段被剪进去了。对。然后他本来会对菲利斯说：“你在给你的继子发调情邮件，菲利斯。”接着他对帕姆说，同时指向菲利斯：“她觉得你的孩子长得很丑。”然后他对吉姆说，同时指向帕姆：“她讨厌你没有
a handyman. A hammock? A hammock? My God, Lee gives me trouble about saying hammock. It has a freaking O in it, everybody. Hammock. How does everybody say it? If you're on vacation with Jenna, you might go lay in a hammock.
杂工就装不好吊床。”吊床？吊床？天哪，莉（Lee）因为我发“吊床”这个词的音而找我的麻烦。大家听着，里面明明有个O字母。吊床（Hammock）。大家都怎么读的？如果你和珍娜一起去度假，你可能会去躺在吊床上。
It's hammock. You know it's hammock. No. Come on. You got to let this one go. Wow. I can't believe I'm saying something correctly. Here's the thing.
是吊床（Hammock）。你知道那是吊床。不对。得了吧。你得放过这个梗。哇。我真不敢相信我居然读对了一个词。事情是这样的。
I bought a hammock for our yard. And you're not allowed to hang it till you know how to say it. To put it up. And the whole time he was like, Jenna, hammock. It has an O in it, H-O-M-M-O-C-K. There's a lot of words in the English language that don't make sense. Let's talk about knife. It has a K in it.
我为我们的院子买了一个吊床。在你学会怎么读这个词之前，你是不准把它挂起来的。把它挂起来。他一整都在说，珍娜，吊床（Hammock）。里面有个O字母，H-O-M-M-O-C-K。英语里有很多单词根本说不通。我们来谈谈“刀”（knife）这个词。里面明明有个K字母。
It's not knife. I know, but that is a common silent K. That's a thing in our language. That is common. It's a thing. You can't. Like the P-H is a fuck. You know? That's we.
它不读作“克赖夫”（knife）。我知道，但这是一个常见的哑音K。这是我们语言中的一种现象。这很常见。这是个规定。你不能这样。就像P-H发F的音一样。你知道吗？那是我们。
Hammock. Hammock. Hammock. My gosh. Anyway. And then he says to Andy, and you told the press, well, lady, there was another unscripted call out that was not, you know, in our shooting draft. It's something Nelson said, and I know what a fantastic improviser he is.
吊床。吊床。吊床。天哪。不管怎样。然后他对安迪说：“你向媒体告密了——”好吧，各位，还有一个未被列入剧本的即兴点名，你知道的，它并不在我们拍摄的初稿里。这是纳尔逊（Nelson）说的话，我知道他是一个多么棒的即兴表演大师。
So I had to ask him if any of his improvs made it into the show. I was curious if this one moment was improvised. And you know, I love improv, and whenever as an improviser, anything you say in the moment makes it in, you are so excited about it. It's like a little private moment of like, woo-hoo, victory. Yes. I asked Nelson if he improvised anything, and here's what he said. Angela is asking me if I improvised anything in this episode in Whistle Blower, and yes,
所以我不得不问他，是否有任何即兴发挥被剪进了剧集中。我很好奇这个瞬间是不是即兴发挥的。你知道的，我热爱即兴表演，每当作为一名即兴演员，你在当时随口说出的话被采用时，你都会为此感到无比兴奋。这就像是一个小小的私密时刻，充满了一种“呜呼，胜利”的感觉。是的。我问纳尔逊他有没有即兴发挥过什么，他是这么说的：安吉拉问我在这集《告密者》里有没有即兴发挥，是的，
I did. I'm so glad you asked me that. It was a great moment for me. As you remember, I sort of, you know, my big final bow is that I come out and sort of hostily quit my job and start calling everyone out, you know, blowing the whistle. I blow the whistle on Andy for leaking the, you know, the printer video, and then I start blowing the whistle on everybody. I'm talking to Kelly, you know, and Ryan, blah, blah, blah.
我有。我很高兴你问我这个。对当时的我和我来说这是一个高光时刻。正如你所记得的，我有点儿，你知道的，我盛大的最后谢幕就是我走出来，有点敌意地辞职，开始点名羞辱每一个人，你知道的，告密。我揭发安迪泄露了，你知道的，打印机视频，然后我开始揭发所有人。我和凯利说话，你知道的，还有瑞恩，巴拉巴拉巴拉。
But the one I improvised was when I turned to Daryl, and I say to him, Daryl, why haven't you told anyone you're on Facebook? People want to be your friend. You're on, you know, and it was this really weird, little weird thing that, and just for the kids back home, back then in 2008 or whatever, Facebook was like Instagram, it was the good one back then. Now they're all terrible. But I didn't have anything to say to Daryl, but I'm a big Craig Robinson fan in general.
但我即兴发挥的那一次是当我转向达里尔（Daryl）时，我对他说：“达里尔，你为什么不告诉任何人你玩脸书（Facebook）？人们都想加你为好友。你在，你知道的……”这是一个非常诡异、有点奇怪的事情，对于当年的孩子们来说，在2008年左右什么的，脸书就像现在的Instagram一样，那是当年最火的社交软件。现在它们都很糟糕。但我当时对达里尔无话可说了，不过我本身就是克雷格·罗宾逊（Craig Robinson）的超级粉丝。
I think he's insanely funny. And so I said that line, which seems sort of inconsequential, but it was really great because of his reaction. You know, they cut to Daryl and he's sort of looking like really ashamed of himself and embarrassed, and that made it all worthwhile for me just to get that, get that out of him. I mean, that's the whole point of ad-libbing stuff, to get an interesting reaction at your scene partner. And Craig is an incredibly good actor, and I loved it.
我觉得他搞笑得超乎想象。所以我说了那句台词，虽然看起来有点无关紧要，但由于他的反应，这真的太棒了。你知道，镜头切到达里尔身上，他看起来对自己感到有点羞愧和尴尬，为了从他身上得到那种反应，这一切对我来说就都值了。我的意思是，即兴发挥的全部意义就在于从你的对手演员那里获得有趣的反应。而且克雷格是一个演技极其精湛的演员，我太喜欢了。
I love that. I love that so much. Oh, it was so funny and so quick, and he's right, like Craig's reaction was perfect. Well, you know, when he flips everyone off at the end, Randy told me that standards and practices made us pixelate his middle finger. Both of them. Yeah, exactly. And Randy said, quote, which was absurd because it made it even more obvious.
我太喜欢了。我太喜欢这个了。哦，太搞笑了，反应也太快了，他说得对，克雷格的反应简直完美。好吧，你知道的，当他在最后向所有人竖中指时，兰迪告诉我，审查标准与规范部门让我们把他的中指打上了马赛克。两个中指都打了。对，没错。兰迪还说，原话是：“这简直荒谬，因为这反而让它更加明显了。”
We fought this note, but unsuccessfully. Should we go back to the plane, lady? Let's go back to the plane because these scenes between Kathy Bates and Steve Krill are so awesome. I could have watched them for an hour. Me too. Yeah, it starts off with Michael kind of confiding to Joe that he's had just the hardest year of his life.
我们据理力争过这个审查意见，但没有成功。我们回飞机上去吧，各位？我们回飞机上去吧，因为凯西·贝茨（Kathy Bates）和史蒂夫·科尔（Steve Krill）之间的这些对手戏实在是太精彩了。我能看上一整小时。我也是。对，故事开始于迈克尔有点向乔倾诉，说他经历了人生中最艰难的一年。
Yeah. His favorite restaurant closed down. Yeah. His second favorite sucks. He bought a video camera to film, I guess, special moments throughout the year, and he only had 12 minutes that were worth taping. Most of that was just birds in his condo complex, which you would like to watch. I would actually.
对。他最喜欢的餐厅关门了。对。他第二喜欢的餐厅烂透了。他买了一台摄像机来拍摄，我猜是为了记录这一整年中那些特别的时刻，而他居然只拍出了12分钟值得保留的画面。大部分内容还都是他公寓大楼里的鸟，而你居然会想看这种东西。我还真想看。
I would watch that. And then he sort of says he misses Holly. And she says, who's Holly? Yeah. Well, then Joe tells Michael that, you know, she's bummed because she thought that as a businesswoman, she'd be breaking the glass ceiling that she'd be a hero to little girls that they might even make a Barbie out of her. She says that the thing that she's really dreading is having to go in front of the press
我会看这个的。然后他顺便说他想念霍莉（Holly）。她说，霍莉是谁？对。好吧，接着乔告诉迈克尔，你知道的，她很沮丧，因为她曾以为作为一名女商人，她会打破玻璃天花板，成为小女孩心目中的英雄，甚至可能有人会以她为原型做一个芭比娃娃。她说她真正感到恐惧的是不得不站在媒体面前
and make one of those apology videos. Yeah. And Michael said, I'll do it. Yeah. He offers to make the apology video. She's like, you don't have to do that. Lady, we had a fan question from Kim See from Langley, British Columbia, Canada in the plane scene.
并录制那种道歉视频。对。迈克尔说：“我去。”对。他主动提出要录制这个道歉视频。她说：“你用不着这么做。”各位，我们在飞机戏中收到了来自加拿大不列颠哥伦比亚省兰利的金·西（Kim See）的粉丝提问。
What do we think? Was Joe manipulating Michael so that he would take the fall and make the video? Or do you think she was really just sharing that she was upset that they sold cheap printers? What do we think? Well, I think she absolutely knew she was manipulating Michael, but I also think she did share a little bit. I think there's some half truth there. But as soon as she said, Mama Joe, you know, when she was like, Mama Joe thought so, Mama
大家觉得呢？你觉得是乔在操纵迈克尔，好让他来当替罪羊并录制视频吗？还是你觉得她真的只是在分享自己因为卖了劣质打印机而感到沮丧的心情？大家怎么看？好吧，我觉得她绝对知道自己在操纵迈克尔，但我也觉得她确实吐露了一点真情。我认为这里面有半真半假成分。但就在她说出“乔妈妈”（Mama Joe）这个称呼时，你知道的，当她说“乔妈妈觉得这样，乔妈妈知道”时，
Joe knew. I was like, she's doing her thing. She does where she kind of compliments you, but then like kind of pulls you in to get what she needs. It's really interesting because I really thought it was just a genuine moment of sharing and that she was completely surprised that Michael offered to make the video. I never saw her as manipulating him. Clearly if Joe invited me to her plane, she could get me to do anything because I just
我就觉得：她开始施展她的那一套了。她就是那种先恭维你，然后像这样把你套牢，好达到她目的的人。这真的很有意思，因为我当时真的以为那只是一个真诚分享的时刻，而且她对迈克尔主动提出录制视频感到无比惊讶。我从来没觉得她在操纵他。显然，如果乔邀请我上她的飞机，她能让我做任何事情，因为我当时完全
bought it. I thought that she did share some truthful things, but the minute she referred to herself as Mama Joe to him, I was like, that was it. That was your clue. Yeah. Okay. I hear that. Now that you say it, I hear it.
相信了。我以为她的确分享了一些真实的想法，但她一向迈克尔自称“乔妈妈”的那一分钟，我就觉得：就是这个。这就是你的线索。对。好吧，我懂了。你这么一说，我听出来了。
Because they're not buddies. She doesn't want him to come visit her in Florida. Why is all of a sudden, she's Mama Joe to him? She needs something. Clearly I want Joe Bennett to like me just like Michael. I am very Michael Scott when it comes to Joe Bennett. I'm like, please invite me to Florida, Joe Bennett. Please take me on your private plane.
因为他们又不是哥们儿。她才不想让他去佛罗里达看她呢。为什么她突然之间就成了他的“乔妈妈”？她有求于人了。很显然，我跟迈克尔一样，也想让乔·贝内特喜欢我。在对待乔·贝内特这件事上，我简直就是迈克尔·斯科特附体。我心里想的是：请邀请我去佛罗里达吧，乔·贝内特。请带我坐你的私人飞机吧。
Please. I'll do whatever. Well, a very smiley Michael ends up making a statement to the press. Yes, he does. And he says there will be no questions. Are there any questions? He's so excited about this role. I will say this, Jenna.
求你了。我什么都愿意做。好吧，一个满脸笑容的迈克尔最后向媒体发表了一份声明。是的，他发表了。并且他说不接受任何提问。请问有什么问题吗？他对这个角色兴奋极了。我得这么说，珍娜，
Maybe I didn't think she was sincere on the plane, but when Joe thanks Michael at the end for making the statement, I think she meant that. Thank you. She was happy. She didn't have to do that. Yes. And she does say to him, is there anything I can do for you? Yeah.
也许我觉得她在飞机上时不够真诚，但当乔在最后感谢迈克尔发表声明时，我觉得她是真心实意的。谢谢你。她很高兴。她不必亲自去面对这一切。是的。而且她确实对他说：“有什么我可以为你做的吗？”对。
And he says, yeah, you can transfer Holly back from Nashua. And he sort of just says that off the cuff, but then she looks at him with all seriousness and says, I'll see what I can do. Well, lady, we had a fan question from Sophia M. and Louisiana, something I didn't think of. In Whistleblower, Michael asked Joe to transfer Holly back to Scranton. But in Secret Santa, David says that Scranton is the only branch that will be kept in the Sabre buyout.
然后他说：“有，你可以把霍莉从纳舒厄（Nashua）调回来。”他这话算是随口一说，但接着她极其认真地看着他说：“我看看我能做点什么。”好吧，各位，我们收到了来自路易斯安那州的索菲亚·M（Sophia M.）的粉丝提问，这是一个我没有想到的问题。在《告密者》中，迈克尔要求乔把霍莉调回斯克兰顿。但在《秘密圣诞老人》（Secret Santa）中，大卫却说斯克兰顿是萨贝尔收购案中唯一保留的分公司。
So technically there is no Nashua. Oh, that's such a good catch. I thought so too. I didn't think of it at all. But yeah. Yeah. So now we're doing this rewatch in real time. I'm very curious.
所以严格来说根本没有纳舒厄分公司了。哦，这个细节抓得太好了。我也这么觉得。我完全没想到这一点。不过是的。好吧，既然我们现在在实时重看这部剧，我很好奇。
Where does Holly come from when she comes back? We will see. I'm sure you all already know. Well, at the end of the episode, everyone's kind of filing out, Andy can't find his bag. Phyllis says it's in the ceiling. They're like hazing Andy. And Phyllis is like, you deserved it. I know.
当霍莉回来时，她是从哪里来的呢？我们会看到的。我确信你们大家肯定都已经知道了。好吧，在这一集的结尾，大家陆续往外走，安迪找不到自己的包了。菲利斯说包在天花板上。他们像是在对安迪进行恶作剧整蛊。菲利斯还说：“你活该。”我知道。
Andy told me that putting Andy's bag in the ceiling was a huge ordeal. He said, you know, our drop ceiling, we had a real ceiling with lights. But it was like, you know, it was suspended from the very high top of our warehouse. And if you opened up the little thing, you would have seen this just cavernous. Yes. It was like we were in an aircraft hangar. Right. It was just low ceiling over us, but if you peel back the ceiling, it was like a catwalk
安迪告诉我，把安迪的包塞进天花板里可是一场大工程。他说，你知道的，我们的吊顶上方其实是一个带有灯光的真正天花板。但它就像是，你知道的，是从我们仓库非常高的顶端悬挂下来的。如果你打开那个小方格，你会发现里面简直别有洞天、空旷无比。是的。那感觉就像我们置身于飞机库里。没错。我们头顶上方是一个低矮的吊顶，但如果你掀开吊顶，上面其实是一条猫道，
of like little railings and bridges and things suspended in the air. Yeah. So he said our production designer, Michael Gallenberg, had to design like a fakie attic, which was basically a black box. Tim James, our construction coordinator, suspended the box over the drop ceiling so that the camera couldn't see all that empty space that went up above the ceiling tiles. That little gag. That little tiny gag.
布满了小栏杆、桥梁以及悬挂在空中的各种东西。对。所以他说我们的布景设计师迈克尔·加伦伯格（Michael Gallenberg）必须设计一个假阁楼，基本上就是一个黑色方盒子。蒂姆·詹姆斯（Tim James），我们的施工统筹，把这个盒子悬挂在吊顶上方，这样摄像机就拍不到吊顶瓷砖上方所有那些空旷的空间了。那个小小的恶作剧。那个微不足道的小恶作剧。
That was many meetings and much construction. Andy is going to get his bag, and then he's going to receive a calf rub, a lingering calf touch. Yeah. From Erin. Yeah. She says she thought he was really brave. Yeah.
那是经过了多次会议和大量施工才完成的。安迪去拿回他的包，然后他收到了一次小腿抚摸，一次依依不舍的小腿触摸。是的。来自艾琳（Erin）。是的。她说她觉得他真的很勇敢。是的。
And that is whistleblower. Yeah. That is the end of season six. You know, lady, we did have this fan question from Natalie F. in San Antonio and Grace V. from Philadelphia who were asking, but who was the real whistleblower? Because there really were a lot of possibilities. There's Pam, Daryl, Kelly, Andy, and David Wallace. I mean, Nick says it was Andy, but really, I feel like it could have been all of us or
这就是《告密者》。是的。这就是第六季的结尾。你知道吗，各位，我们确实收到了来自圣安东尼奥的娜塔莉·F（Natalie F.）和来自费城的格蕾丝·V（Grace V.）的粉丝提问，他们问：究竟谁才是真正的告密者？因为现实中真的有很多种可能。有帕姆、达里尔、凯利、安迪和大卫·华莱士。我的意思是，尼克说是安迪，但实际上，我觉得可能我们所有人都是，又或者
any of us. What do you think, Ange? Yeah. Any one of those people could have spoke to the right person that then ended up somehow coming back on them, right? They were all being pretty chatty about it. I think Andy is the one who, with great intention, wrote this email to the press. He said he didn't want, you know, people's houses to burn down or people to be injured
我们中的任何一个人都有可能。你觉得呢，安吉？是的。这些人中的任何一个都可能对不对的人说过这事，然后这事最终不知怎么又反作用到他们自己身上了，对吧？他们当时都在喋喋不休地谈论这件事。我觉得安迪是那个怀着极大的意图给媒体写了这封电子邮件的人。他说他不想，你知道的，让人们的房子被烧毁，或者让人们
because of these faulty printers. I also thought it was interesting when I spoke to Nelson that Nelson said Nick the IT guy was also a whistleblower of his own because he went around and called out everyone in the office. He sure was. Well, listen, a big thank you to Randy Cordray for all of his great facts this week and also to Nelson Franklin for sending in those great audio clips. Nelson was most recently in the miniseries Gaslit, and you can find him on Instagram
因为这些有缺陷的打印机而受伤。我也觉得很有意思的是，当我跟纳尔逊交谈时，纳尔逊说尼克这个IT男其实也是他自己的告密者，因为他四处走动，点名羞辱了办公室里的每一个人。他确实是。好吧，听着，非常感谢兰迪·科德雷（Randy Cordray）这周提供的所有精彩幕后花絮，同时也非常感谢纳尔逊·富兰克林（Nelson Franklin）发来的这些精彩音频片段。纳尔逊最近参演了迷你剧《煤气灯下》（Gaslit），你可以在Instagram上找到他，
at NelsonModeSquad. And Jenna, before we go, I have one last audio clip from Nelson. It was so sweet, and I wanted you to hear it. Thanks so much for having me, guys, again, and I want to say a special thanks to Jenna. As I mentioned several times, the Job Fair was my first job ever as an actor, and it was on my favorite show, and I was very, very scared and stressed out, and my scene was with Jenna. Thank God, because, you know, she's the sweetest, greatest person, so you made me feel very
账号是NelsonModeSquad。珍娜，在我们结束之前，我还有纳尔逊发来的最后一段音频。这段话太甜了，我想让你听听。非常感谢你们邀请我来做客，伙计们，我想特别感谢珍娜。正如我多次提到的那样，那场招聘会（Job Fair）是我作为演员的份工作，而且它发生在我最喜欢的剧里，当时我非常非常害怕和紧张，我的对手戏又是和珍娜一起拍的。谢天谢地，因为，你知道的，她是世上最甜美、最棒的人，所以你让我感到非常
comfortable and you let me thrive. So thank you a million times for starting my acting career on a good foot. I really, really appreciate it. And thanks for having me on again. Love you guys. Nelson. Is that so sweet? That is so sweet.
自在，并让我得以发挥。所以非常感谢你让我的演艺生涯有了一个好的开端。我真的、真的很感激。也谢谢你们再次邀请我。爱你们。纳尔逊。这话是不是超级甜？太甜了。
I want to say, again, I would have never known that that was his first acting job. He was so calm, cool, and collected. I learned that here with his audio clips. He was great and is great. Nelson, thank you so much for sitting in your audio clips. It was so great to catch up with you, and you guys, we will see you back here for Season 7. Next week.
我想说的是，如果不是他自己说，我绝对不会知道那是他的第一份演艺工作。他当时表现得那么冷静、沉着、淡定。我是通过他这里的音频片段才得知这一点的。他过去很棒，现在也很棒。纳尔逊，非常感谢你发来这些音频片段。能和你叙旧真是太棒了，伙计们，我们第七季节目再见。下周见。
See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com.
到时见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍和安吉拉·金西共同制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍（Cody Fisher）。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins），我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer），我们的助理制作人是艾insley·布比科（Ainsley Bubicoe）。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）演唱的《橡胶树》（Rubber Tree）。如需收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。
For a free one-month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如需在Stitcher Premium免费试用一个月，请使用优惠码：Office。本集尚无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。